>> From the library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Gail Shirazi: Hello,
I'm Gail Shirazi
of the Israel-Judaica section
of the Library of congress.
I want to welcome you to today's
program, Forgotten Transports.
Before we begin I would
like to mention some
of our upcoming programs,
there's a list of them
on the table in the back.
Tomorrow we have a program on the
Judische Kulturbund and that's
at 12:00 in the Mary Pickford.
And next week we have a
Alona Frankel coming to speak
about her new book of
memoires called, Girl.
I would like to mention that
today's program is co-sponsored
by the European division, motion
picture recorded sound division,
Hebraic language table in
cooperation with the Embassy
of the Czech Republic and the
Rabin Chair at GW University.
I want to thank the European
Division, Mike Mashon at MBRS,
Audrey Fisher in the Public Affairs
Office, Gelena Tavoroski [phonetic]
of our section, the Law
Library and their staff.
Mary Fesco [phonetic]
and the Czech Embassy.
And I would like to welcome from the
Czech Embassy the Head of Diplomacy,
where are you Pablo, over there?
And the Cultural Attache of the
Czech embassy, right over there.
Thank you for coming and for
doing all these wonderful programs
with us.
Our speaker Lukas Pribyl, studied
politics and Near Eastern studies
at Brandeis University and the
Hebrew University in Jerusalem.
He studied religion and human
rights at Columbia University,
history of the Central
European University in Budapest
and Jewish Religion and
Philosophy in Sweden.
He's published on various aspects of
Jewish history and curated exhibits
at the Jewish Museum in Prague.
He's also served as
the first Director
of the European Shoah
Legacy Institute
and currently he's Director of the
Czech Cultural Center in Tel Aviv.
Lukas will show clips and
discuss his body of work
for award winning films, followed
by the Q & A. This is being webcast
so if you do not wish to appear
in the webcast please leave during
the question and answer period
and please shut off
your cell phones.
So now the floor, Lukas.
[ Applause ]
>> Lukas Pribyl: Good morning, thank
you very much for coming to see me,
I have to admit this is a
very strange occasion for me
because I'm used to
talking after the films
and now what's really puzzling
myself with how to talk
about my films without
revealing too much
and still making you
to come and see them.
And today at four in the morning
I, very jet-lagged woke up,
opened the internet, found out the
results of the election and sort
of had this moment of enlightenment.
And decided to completely change
my talk because I realized
that everything I do and
everything I've studied,
the thing that I'm
interested in most is stories.
And talking about films which is
a story in itself or four films
in this case which creates
and even larger picture,
and actually tell a bigger story.
It's so hard that I decided that
I'm going to speak a little bit
about the story behind the
films, not the films themselves.
And if you find the story
behind the films interesting,
hopefully you will go and
see the films themselves
and find the films
interesting as well.
So, people often ask me
how I got to make films,
since as you've heard I'm
not a film maker by training
and my primary focus was
always politics and history.
And now I have to say it was the
stories really that brought me to it
because and why the Holocaust,
it goes back to my
childhood love of guns.
Because I could never own a
gun, not even a plastic one
and I always wanted it because
all the kids on the playground
of course ran around with these
plastic toys and my mom would never,
ever allow me to have one.
One day I managed to
borrow one from a friend,
whose name I still remember, David.
And came home and I grew up
in communist Czechoslovakia
where you had all these
Russian movies
with people fighting the
Germans and the Germans running
around with machine
guns and shouting,
[foreign language], hands up.
I know a little bit of German
because my mom sometimes spoke
to my grandfather in German when
they didn't want me to understand,
but I didn't know what that means,
I just saw it from the movies.
So, I snuck up on my grandfather
and shouted [Foreign language]
and I'll never forget his face
because he turned completely white.
And sort of froze and I dropped
the gun, I ran away crying
and since then I haven't touched
a gun, plastic one or real.
And I realized there is something
in the past of my grandfather
that it's strange, it's
not completely normal.
And it was -- I realized it more and
more because I grew up surrounded
by these elderly ladies
without families
and they always swooned on me.
Because whenever they saw a kid --
they came and I still remember sort
of from my perspective of a kid
was they are coming down on me
and pinching my cheeks and I
was totally terrified of them.
So I even used to say whenever
I saw one of them approaching,
I would say [Foreign
language] which meant my name,
the city I was born in,
because that was one
of the questions they always
asked, like they wouldn't know.
And my age, which was
eight, I don't know why
because I probably didn't
know any other number then.
And but later on I realized that
these ladies do not have kids
of their own because they
all lost them during the war
and during the Holocaust.
And as I was growing up I kind
of thought about the Holocaust
as something that everyone
goes through.
Like you go to the army, you know
you go to the camp, it's normal
and then as I was in high school
I realized it's not actually
completely normal to go
to a concentration camp
and I started finding out more
about my family and the 60 people
who did not make it in my family.
And my mom and mom and my aunt
they didn't really know much
because my grandmother
died just as I was born
and my grandfather never
really spoke about it.
But I was getting more and
more interested in this history
and especially about the
history of my grandfather
because I really loved him and
he influenced me tremendously.
And now I found out that
he was actually deported
in the very first deportation
of the second world war,
which was already in October 1939.
I was you could call it Eichmann's
first deportation scheme,
when the Nazi's were really
learning how to deport people.
The whole scheme didn't work
out, it was quite unsuccessful,
they deported a lot of people
from Moravia from Ostrava
where my family is
from, upper Silesia
but the camp itself couldn't
actually -- they were building it,
the deportees themselves
were building it.
It couldn't accommodate
all the prisoners and a lot
of them were chased out
or escaped from the camp
to the Soviet occupied part
of Poland when the Germans
and Russians were --
Nazis' and Soviets.
Divided up the territory
of Poland and ended up,
most of them were picked up by
the [foreign language] of the KGB.
And I'll come back to the KGB
later but I searched their archives
and ended up in the Klooga that's
how some of these people survived.
And my grandfather was one of 20
who actually went through Nisko
and subsequently was returned to
Ostrava which was very strange
in the history of concentration
camps
or camps, Nazi camps in general.
And then he was subsequently
deported again.
My grandfather died when I
was 10, but I was rummaging
through his stuff and I
actually found photographs
from Nisko, from the camp.
And at that time I realized that
there is actually visual material
of almost everything, it just
needs a lot of luck or a lot
of persistence to find it.
And I started to be interested, not
only in the history of the Holocaust
but also in sort of the
visual part of the Holocaust,
about the visual record of it.
Because watching a lot of
documentaries I realize
that they do not really
depict the life
of the people who went through it.
In the most crucial periods, you
have a lot of footage that comes
from the period just
before the Holocaust
or just after the Holocaust.
So you have footage from German
news fields with Nazi's marching
with torches and so on, but that's
not the perspective of the Jews
because you would have to be crazy
or suicidal to go to a Nazi march.
You closed your window and you tried
to pretend that you're not home.
So this was not the
experience of the Jews,
and then you have what you can
call the post-Holocaust footage.
The liberation footage, but this
is again something that is more
from the perspective
of the liberators
and this is the aftermath,
this is the end.
But what happened in between
and that's was really what
I was most interested in.
And when I was researching this
coverage actually turned out to be
in my BA thesis, I realized that
there were so many other places
that nothing is known about them.
There's nothing that's been written
about, there are no documentaries
about Krakow, Izbica,
Luta, all these places
where Czech Jews were deported, so
I was mostly focusing on Czech Jewry
and Central European Jewry.
And I couldn't really find anything
about that except for the names
of these camps or rather places
and why wasn't there anything
because most of these places ceased
existing already 1943, 44 at most,
they were liquidated
and they were liquidated
with all the people in them.
So the survival rate was
really not even percentages,
it was less than that.
We have come to associate Auschwitz
with all the evil because it was
such a huge death factory but these
much smaller places were often
equally deadly or even more so.
And I realized that from about
40% of Czech Jews did not perish
in these big extermination centers
but rather in places in Latvia,
Estonia, Belarus, Eastern Poland and
so I decided that when I was looking
for this material on Nisko I started
collecting all the other material I
could find on these other camps.
Then eventually I actually
met some of the first people
who survived these places
and I realized that none
of them had been interviewed before.
And often their experience
was so different
from the survivor's stories that
we know the [inaudible] number
who have them on the arm
and the stripped uniforms.
That they often even
were not part of the sort
of the survivor's circles, or
sort of fell through the cracks,
that were not interviewed by
these big interviewing schemes
like Spielberg's Foundation
and so on.
So, I started approaching
them and I was thinking
that what would be the best
medium to capture the history
and what they were saying, what
they were telling me and realized
that the book was not
doing it justice.
Because the people were
themselves so interested,
as I told you at the very beginning,
I'm most interested in stories
and people have stories and people
tell stories in a certain way.
And it's really important to see
how they are telling the stories
and the humor and the gestures
and the facial expressions
and that's the only way to
capture that is on film.
I can write a book but book is quite
difficult because you have to work
with the imagination of the reader.
And the reader has to be an
active participant really.
But film is the most approachable
media because you can screen it
to a hall full of high school kids.
And if it has a story they might
at the very beginning you know,
not pay any attention but
they slowly get into it
and they watch it,
they won't read a book.
So, I decided to make films,
not being a film maker it might have
been a bit of a audacious enterprise
but I know a lot of
people in the film world.
And I think if you work hard, I
knew exactly what I wanted to do
and if you work with good people,
and I managed to assemble a really
good team, you can do films even
if you're not a film maker.
And now when I was thinking how
to do the films I realized again
watching a lot of documentaries
that most of them are told again,
from the perspective of the Nazi,
from the perspective
of the liberators
or from the perspective
of the narrator.
But this is like a bird's eye
view, we are talking on behalf
of the witnesses and
I wanted the people
to tell their stories themselves.
So, one of the first decisions
that I took making these films was
that there won't be any narration.
That I won't have a commentary, that
everything will be told basically
from bottom up and that
I'll take the interviews
and these very narrow perspectives
of the individual people
that I recorded and create
the picture from that.
Because even films that I really
admire like [inaudible] for example,
there you don't have a narration but
you have commentary by historians
which is just a more sophisticated
version of a commentary.
So, I wanted to have the Jewish
perspective and even though we went
and interviewed also the so-called
bystanders and quite a few Nazis
or Nazi affiliated troops from
the country's they occupied,
I did not want to include
that in the film.
I wanted to be consistent
with that one perspective.
And so in the end it worked
out that they were four films,
each of the films is focused on
one destination where transports
of Czech Jews left too and on
one particular group of people
and we can call it
a mode of survival.
Of course it's not a
recipe for survival
because there is no such thing.
You only know what works in a
particular set of conditions
after you survive if
you're lucky enough.
But basically, they were
done in a chronological order
as the transports left and the
very transports left for Riga
and for Latvia in early 1942 and the
film about Latvia is really a story
of families, how they tried to cope
in completely atrocious conditions
of the Riga Ghetto and keep
a semblance of normalcy.
So children went to school but on
the way to school they actually had
to pass by the gallows where
there was always someone hanging
and things like that.
The film about Belarus is
really a story of men only
because from the deportees
to Belarus there was a single female
survivor, all the other people --
all the other survivors were men.
And it's really a film about
resistance, both armed and unarmed,
but mostly armed of people escaping
from the camps, from the death camps
and joining the partisans
and fighting.
The third film in the series about
Estonia is the story of women only
because unlike in Belarus there
were absolutely no male survivors
from the deportees to Estonia.
And there were only women and they
survived in a very strange way
because they sort of created
large living organisms.
They bonded so much that they gave
up their individual
thinking you can say
and now they did everything together
which greatly helped
them to survive.
They really surrounded themselves
by this bubble and they refused
to believe what was
going on around them.
They convinced themselves
that they'll survive,
that they will come back and
that they'll meet their families.
It was an illusion, their families
of course they were already dead,
but this is what kept them going.
And the last film about the 14,000
Czech deportees to the Lublin region
of that which 50 people survived
and they all survived thanks
to running away and basically
it's a film about identity.
Because to escape you
have to assume a new name,
you have to assume a new story,
you have to believe your
story enough to be convincing.
But at the same time when I
talked to the people who lived
under this assumed identity, they
told me you can't lose yourself
in this identity too much
because the moment you become
that person you stop being
careful and that's when you die.
So this constant acting that you
act, that it stops being acting
but you still have to keep in
mind that you are someone else,
that you're pretending
to be someone.
And so these four films
actually stand on their own,
can be screened independently,
have their own structure
but if you see all four
of them together there is an
overarching logic to them.
So, I would never use a story
that I tell in one film,
won't be in another film.
So, there are certain horizontal
themes, the love or shoes
for example, so in the film
about Latvia you learn how shoes
can help you get food for your kids.
In Belarus how shoes make you an
unlikely and unwittingly a war hero,
in Estonia how you survived
selection thanks to shoes.
And in Poland what
happens if you lose them.
So, there are these stories
that connect the films
but they work on their own.
So, in the films also I decided
that as I told you about the Nisko
and the story of the
pictures that I found.
I decided that I'll illustrate
everything in the films by time
and place, precise pictures, that I
won't use any make believe footage,
no postwar footage unless
it's really of liberation.
But I won't -- what really annoys
me in many documentaries is
that for example someone
is talking about Dachau.
And you see footage
from Bergen-Belsen
and it's actually something that
really undermines the message
because first become
immune to these images
because they just recycle
it, recycles too much.
And second also the deniers of
the Holocaust use this as a proof,
look you just have some footage and
keep recycling it and always claim
that this is some other place.
So, I decided that I'll
really look for it everywhere,
which ended up being
over 30 countries.
And we filmed in over 20
countries on five continents
and the material really comes
from all kinds of sources,
but I'll come back to that.
The most important thing at the very
beginning was to find the people
and as I mentioned 80 or 90%
of them had not been interviewed
before and kind of got lost.
Because I had relatively very
precise deportation records,
I had rather accurate
survival records
because people mostly came back.
When they came back from the war
they registered with the communities
and they wanted to
look for their families
and so on so they registered.
Even though I did find some
people who were not on these lists
because having survived and
actually having witnessed the death
of their families they had
no reason to go home and left
for another country immediately.
So, for example in Australia
we found a mother and daughter
who survived the Riga Ghetto,
the mother was the oldest person
that we interviewed, she was 103
years old when we talked to her.
Because I looked for everyone
at that time until the age
of 100 and she was over that.
So I started with these
lists of survivors,
then I went through marriage
records because a lot
of the women married
shortly after the war.
And also, not always I could find it
but name change records because one
of the funny things in Czech is
that you will have a lot of people
with German sounding names.
They're mostly not
Jewish because a lot
of the Jewish families changed
their German sounding surnames
after the war to Czech
sounding ones.
And then of course immigration
records which were really helpful
because not always they
told me where they went
but the more you know
the more you can judge
where these people could
have immigrated to.
Depending on the year, so in 1945
people who left were people who went
as far as possible, New Zealand,
Australia, those were people
who knew that there
was no one who survived
and they just went directly.
And they wanted to be as far
away from Europe as possible,
1948 was another big wave
of immigration and most
of these people went to North
America and South America.
And surprisingly they did not go
to Israel and I was wondering why
and it was because the
survival rate from the places
that I was researching was
so low there were actually
individual survivors.
Israel at least in its inception
was a very collective country
and people left there
collectively too.
But these people did not have
any friends from the camps,
they had no relatives, they
were only by themselves.
So unless they belonged to
some let's say Zionist movement
or youth movement before the war and
they actually managed to reconnect
with someone they knew from
before the war, they did not leave
in this immigration wave.
And then there was a third wave in
1968 when the Soviets and the Soviet
in fact invaded Czechoslovakia
and surprisingly these
people went mostly to Germany
but by then it was not so surprising
because they knew the language.
They were middle aged so
they often had families
and if they had a son they knew
that the son would not have to go
to the army being Jewish
which in the 60's was quite an
important factor.
Also they already had new
friends and new relationships
that they established after the
war in postwar Czechoslovakia
and it's much easier to keep in
touch with someone in Czechoslovakia
across the iron curtain from
Germany than from Australia.
So there were other factors they
got citizenship almost instantly,
they got some financial
help and so on.
And Germany by then was a,
I'm talking about the
western part of it.
So by then it actually did a
great deal of identification
so this helped me to
look for the people.
But still they were
often not registered,
the people I was specifically
looking
for were often not registered with
the Jewish communities and so on.
So searching for them this
way turned rather futile,
what helped me most and my
mom still hates me for it
because we still have
hundreds of phone books
and now Jews are city people
so when they left they
usually settled in cities.
And if you could at least tell
in which direction they went,
let's say some other American
city I collected phone books
from the big cities and if
the name was not too common,
I just started calling everyone
of that particular name.
And you can always tell whether
you called the right person
by the reaction, because you
dial and you say excuse me,
I'm not sure I'm calling the right
person but were you in Salaspils?
And if they say what,
you got the wrong person,
if they ask who are you, what do you
want you know you hit the jackpot.
Now you couldn't do it, actually
now you have Mr. Goggle to help you
but it's much more difficult now
because no one has
land lines anymore.
Everyone has a cell phone and the
cell phones are not registered
so actually I was working
in this perfect timing
because you already had
some phone books online,
you already could Google, not
pre-Google whatever that was.
Look up some stuff online but
you could still reach people
through the phones, so this search
would not be successful now.
And once you find the person you
have to convince him or her to talk
to you which often took
me up to two years.
As I mentioned, these people
were often very wounded
and sometimes they even
felt that they are shunned
by the other survivors
because our preconception is
that if something is
horrible we hear about it.
So we know that Auschwitz
was absolutely atrocious,
so it must have been horrible but
have you heard about Luta, no,
means it couldn't have been that
bad there because if it were
so bad you would have
heard about it.
But the fact is no
one survived Luta.
So if you say I survived Salaspils,
the other survivors often say
so what, you know I was
in a much worse place,
you can't understand it.
So these people didn't want to
talk and sometimes I had to go
for example, one of the most
crucial witnesses was living
in New York, a fantastic lady.
I went to see her in New York
three times and always as we set
up the camera, she just
said okay, I can't do it.
So you had to be quite persistent in
and why indeed did they talk to me?
It was because, I think it
was because first I got lucky
with the timing, because most of
these people were advanced in age
and they started to realize
that if they don't tell
it now, they never will.
Second, the atmosphere
changed because thanks
to these big interviewing
schemes even though they chose not
to participate in them, other
people around them were talking
and that makes a huge difference.
And also their whole lives they
were looking ahead, they were trying
to raise families, work,
what so ever all these things
but now they had actually
time to reflect.
So that was a helping factor
and then also I realized
that when they were approached by --
and they told me themselves
when they were approached
by interviewers, even in
the cases when they were,
the questions were wrong.
Because the places that they
survived were so specific,
that the general questions
for -- without diminishing it,
the general survivor
of the Holocaust would not
fit and they get upset.
When I talked to them they
realized that I know sometimes more
than they do because
I knew the context,
I knew the background,
I knew the documents.
And very often it happened that
they actually started talking to me
like I was there even though
I was 70 years younger
than they, sometimes.
They started talking to me
like I was there with them
and they said do you remember when
they separated us and we went there
and there and of course
I couldn't remember it
but it I knew what happened.
And I knew the names
they were mentioning
which also greatly helped me
to cross check the
information they were giving me.
There were some incredible
stories really,
I think the people really wanted
to tell but they were waiting
for someone who would match
their idea of who to tell it.
It's very difficult to tell it
to someone from your family,
you'd almost never do that but if
you have someone who knows enough
that you can relate it to,
but at the same time doesn't
really show much emotion.
I will come back to it, I had
to develop my own interviewing
technique then you can get
this information.
And sometimes you had
really incredible stories,
for example you flew half way
around the world to Denver,
I remember this interview very well
because when I was flying back I
landed and the Twin Towers went
down on the day I landed.
But we had this interview set
up with this old gentleman
who was a survivor of a labor camp,
Treblinka, which was right next
to the death camp, very
few people know about it.
And [inaudible] and me decided
not to tell it in the film
but it was an important interview.
When we arrived to Denver we found
out that the man was in a comma.
So, I talked to the family and his
daughter said look, I'm okay with it
if you want go and talk to him,
I mean he's dying and I talked
to the physicians and they said
there's nothing to lose, sure.
We went and when I started
talking, whispering into his ear,
the man suddenly sat up with
you know, a pipe in his arms
and had the black Kriah on, he
wasn't religious before the war
but he turned religious
after [inaudible].
And he talked to us on camera for
two hours then he said good-bye
to his family and died
12 hours later.
And it was literally seeing
someone rise from the dead to tell
that story and it was quite
incredible experience.
So, yes I was partly lucky but
you have to ask the right question
and I mentioned that I developed
my own interview technique
because I read a lot of books
about psychology and police manuals
about how to interrogate
people and things like that.
But nothing would fit perfectly and
then I realized that I both trust
and mistrust human memory.
It can be an excellent source but
you have to be very careful with it
and my most favorite answer
from anyone is, I don't know.
Because the moment people
tell you I don't know,
they're reliable witnesses.
What happened -- I was also
lucky because I was interviewing
from places that were so unknown
that there were no
documentaries, no books.
So there was no integration of
postwar knowledge into their memory
and for example I interviewed a
lot of people from Auschwitz also.
And basically almost everyone
tells you, and there was Mengele
and he was sending people
to the left and to the right
and I came there and I was
sent there and my family.
The memory itself is correct but
Mr. Mengele wasn't standing there
and saying hello, you know, good
morning, welcome to Auschwitz
and we go to the -- I'm
Mengele and go to the right.
How did they know the name, it's
after, they remember the face
of the officer but there
were dozens of officers
who were carrying out
these selections.
Mengele is just a symbol, so this
is a name that's floating around
and you attach it to the --
but it already makes the
interview somewhat slanted.
Because you know that they
talked to other survivors,
they read books, saw documentaries.
The same thing that for example,
I survived a handful of people
who were in Auschwitz
almost for the duration
of its existence from Slovakia.
And I asked them when you
arrived, where did you get off?
And to me there was this pause,
you could see them thinking
and they said, on the ramp.
And there was no ramp in
1942, it was built in 1944.
But because 99.9% who survived
Auschwitz say they got off
on the ramp which in
their case is correct.
They doubted their own memories
because they thought all
these people cannot be wrong,
so they started justifying their own
memory by saying, but I think I was
in at the back and we stood
a little bit behind the ramp
so we were actually
jumping into mud.
But it was because
there was no ramp.
So with the way my witnesses, I
was actually lucky in the sense
that they often answered I
don't know, I wasn't there.
And knowing even names for example
I memorized because I was looking
for every single person on the list
to find material, I
knew them by heart.
So they often mentioned -- but
do you remember Peter and he was
in love with this blond
girl, what was her name.
And I know the name but I would
never provide this information,
so I offer five names and if they
pick the right one it confirms
another interview that I have.
And so -- another thing that kind of
united the witnesses that I talked
to was that they're extremely
intelligent people but most
of them were not philosophers,
what I call philosophers.
People who are into
introspection and they tend
to relive their memories.
Because if you revisit your
memory too often you change it,
I noticed it when I was talking
to high schools for example,
and sometimes you can already
-- you hear the questions,
the questions tend to repeat
themselves and I know what works
and doesn't work with the audience.
So even when telling my own
story of making the film,
I think it changes I can do.
It's like with a joke
that you tell often,
the more often you tell
it the better you tell it
but it's very different,
a hundred time
than the first time you tell it.
And so I admire people
for example who can go --
survivors who can go to
schools and tell their stories
but I would never use them
in the film because I know
that the story is no longer
the story that I want to hear.
I wanted to, it's like
with a diamond you know
if you find it a rough diamond
it looks like any other stone,
you have to polish it
and then it takes shape.
But it's a very different stone,
so for example you can always tell
watching a documentary whether
someone is talking for
the first time or not.
But lots of documentaries
actually I find very realistic
but half the people in the film,
you see how they are tearing up.
People who speak for the first
time they never cry because it's
so difficult to actually if you lock
something inside yourself for 50,
60, 70 years to tell it after such
a long time, it takes so much energy
and concentration that you don't
actually have energy left to cry.
It's only the second, third
time that you are telling it
that you gain the distance
from your own story
and then you can start actually
feeling sorry about yourself
and that's when you start crying.
It works, I mentioned the police
manuals, it actually works,
if the trauma is really fresh
then you have different reactions,
you have tears or not but
with the distance you know
in time you usually don't
get that on the very first --
when you're telling the
story for the first time.
Regarding the interviewing
technique also I realized
that when you are convincing
people to talk and sometimes one
of the things that I
used was with people
who did not want to talk to me.
I knew that deep down
they really wanted to talk
but how to convince them.
So I introduced everyone
around them, their friends,
completely unrelated topic
about the Holocaust sometimes
and then they eventually they
come back to you and say, okay,
so why is everyone so
interesting and I'm not?
And I said well two years ago
I asked you for an interview
and about 50 times
in the meantime, so.
But then they start talking and when
you finally agree to an interview,
you start to prepare -- like today
I woke up at four in the morning
and decided I'm going
to talk to somebody
about something completely else,
but that's a different story.
But before that I was
actually preparing a talk,
thinking of what I'm
going to tell you
and usually you structure
the story chronologically.
You decide what you're going to
include and what you're going
to leave out, but it's your call
what you consider interesting
which is usually the things
that they considered interesting,
but not so interesting.
And the things that they leave out
are the most interesting to you.
So, you have to get those
other things but in a way
that they don't realize
that you're doing it.
Because very often these
things are the most traumatic
or they are things when they are
not completely sure that they acted
in a moral way or that
the decision was right.
Or very often there's some kind
of sexual abuse, things like that
that they keep for themselves.
So, I let them start telling
the story the way they want
and they eventually they
get used to the light.
They forget about the
camera in the corner
and they get more comfortable
with you.
Then I start asking very, very
specific targeted questions
that completely break
down the narrative
and make a complete mess of it.
Because one of the basic things
is that whatever question you ask,
you get an answer of equal length.
So, if you ask something
general you get an answer
that lasts let's say three minutes.
If you ask a very, very specific
question you get also three minutes
but the three minutes you
have so much more detail
in those three minutes of course.
And so, by ways of
association and it looks
like these questions are completely
chaotic but I know what I'm doing
and then I say, oh sorry I got
completely confused now can you
please tell me again.
I totally don't understand
what was happening
and they start telling you the
story again but with all the details
that they skipped at
the very beginning.
And it's also good for editing
because you have the story both
in a condensed version, a longer
version and so you can work
with that in terms of film.
You do look like an idiot
asking these questions
but you know that's the
price you have to pay for it.
And you have to stay neutral because
people are really like a mirror,
you can very often in documentaries,
you can focus on the
people who are talking.
You can see what the
facial expression
of the interviewer was,
because they reflect it.
And so, even though they're telling
something absolutely horrible,
you cannot really show horror
and that also helps you to get
across the individual moments
when they start to break down.
Because you say look we have a job
to do, you agreed to this interview
so please let's get on with it.
And they start talking, the moment
you sympathize with them too much,
of course you sympathize, of course
it hurts you and them, everyone
but you can't show it too much.
Because it might destroy the
interview and now my interviews tend
to be very, very long
sometimes 12 hours.
And that's when you really
go through these very,
very specific questions
because of course I know
that I'm not going to
use them in the film.
And we filmed over 400 hours, I'm
not talking about some extra footage
that places that were disappearing
at that time or interviews
with bystanders and
some of the Nazis.
We might come back to that if we
have time, which I should check,
okay we don't have much time.
So I'll show you also some clips,
I decided not to use any clips
from the film themselves because
the films are each 90 minutes long.
And they're linear stories, so
they're sentenced by one person
and another sentence
by another person
and without the context you
don't really get the picture.
But I'll show you some for
example I mentioned the Salaspils,
there's one man he's
talking in English also.
And I'll show you some of
the material that I found
because as I said I believe there
is a visual record of everything,
so this is from a camp
called Salaspils in Latvia.
>> And in the morning when you woke
up the person on your right was dead
and the person on your
left was dying
and the person behind you didn't
get up and you were very surprised
that you are still around.
That you are still
functioning relatively normally,
relatively normally.
Relative to the condition in which
you got up and went down and lined
up on the [inaudible] and stood in
the subzero temperatures for an hour
or so before you went to work.
>> Lukas Pribyl: So, the photographs
that you saw in the film,
they are really of
Salaspils in 1942,
I could even identify certain
people on some of the pictures.
And the material, I told you already
how I was looking for people,
I was looking the same way
for photographs or footage.
Very often I found it, it
depends on the place but let's say
in Poland I went around and I traded
bottles of vodka for photographs.
I felt a little bit
like a Santa Clause
because they already knew
whenever I drove into the village
and my trunk was full of alcohol.
And you got drunk with the men
and suddenly they started
bringing you these photographs.
Because the camps in the Lublin
region they usually did not have a
permanent Nazi unit stationed there,
the Nazi officers actually
administered several camps
and the camps were
themselves run by Ukraine.
They called them [inaudible] blacks
because of their black uniforms.
And of course these soldiers,
they had access to the warehouses
where the property
stolen from the Jews was.
And they went out with the Polish
village girls and the transports
from Czech, they were
rich transports,
stuff they never saw
in eastern Poland.
So, they were, the girls were --
the perfumes and all that stuff
and even though it was forbidden
the Jews always brought a camera.
One of them, it was
in the warehouse,
the Ukrainians didn't know
how to operate cameras
but they wanted a picture
with their girlfriends.
So, they asked the Jew to take a
picture and you have the [inaudible]
with his girlfriend and the entire
village standing behind them
because they also wanted
in the picture.
Because most of the places were so
poor that you had pictures taken
at your baptism, marriage and
then strange enough custom
of your dead body in a coffin.
But those were the only pictures
that you would accumulate
throughout your life,
so they all wanted pictures.
And the Jews who knew how to
take a camera took pictures
of the villagers and
traded them, they loved them
and traded them for food.
So, very often in the houses
there you find the same picture
because they made multiple copies
and they gave them
to people for food.
But you have to go through
the houses and funny enough
when you get drunk with the
men they, they are now married
to these girlfriends
of these Ukrainians.
And they never forget
because even during
and after the war there was
a sort of a civil war going
on between the e and the
Ukrainians and they never forgot
and forgave their wives for
going out with a Ukrainian.
So -- and the women always keep
pictures, men don't but women do
and soldiers keep pictures
because those are the most sort
of the best times of their lives.
So, they always know where the women
have the pictures, they get drunk,
they start rummaging
through a closet,
take out the shoe box
with the photos.
And they tell you this is my wife,
this is the Ukrainian,
they remember his name.
And they can name even some
of the Jews on the pictures
and that's how you for
example find pictures.
Another one was Jews were
used for slave labor,
mostly digging [Foreign
language] the drainage canals,
it's a very swampy region.
But it's technically
quite a difficult task,
so you had to had Poles
from the cities,
engineers come and
design these works.
And they had cameras, so they took
pictures of themselves with the Jews
from western and central Europe.
Because they had much more
in common with these people
than with the poor villagers
-- with the Poles themselves.
But the Poles from the
village remembered the names
of these engineers so
they give me the name.
I go and I look up all the
people of that name in Poland,
then I find the engineer, I find the
family usually, they have an album.
I take the album, I go back to the
village and they identify the people
and that's how you find pictures.
The same thing works with
Nazis, Germans are people
who do not move much, so even
when there were postwar trials
and investigations of Nazis
I find an old address.
And I go to the town
and I find the families
and they always have something
because soldiers never give
up their pictures even though
often it's basically incriminating
evidence against them,
they mostly keep it.
So there are many, many
other techniques like this,
I don't know if I have -- how
much time do we have [inaudible].
Okay, I'll play some more
-- I'll play this one.
[Foreign language]
>> Lukas Pribyl: Yeah,
so that's for the example
that people don't actually
cry, that they're on the brink
but if they're telling
it for the first time
like this lady in Switzerland.
They don't go over and that's
the moment how you can also judge
whether they're actually
talking for the first time.
Basically, these clips are clips of
interviews with some illustrations,
they're not completely
part of the films
or sometimes I use
a sentence or two.
But I think they illustrate
what I'm saying better
than the films themselves because in
the film there's literally a story
behind every photograph,
every story I mentioned.
KGB for example, I smuggled stuff
from the KGB archives in Belarus,
the KGB is still called the KGB.
And they wouldn't let me in, I
wrote them a letter many times,
never received an answer
until I went there personally
when I finally got
my visas to Belarus
and they wouldn't let
me into the archives.
So I decided that the only way is to
contact the director but the names
of directors, I don't know how it
is here but FBI or CIA or whatever.
But they're not exactly
listed in phone books.
So there was still not too many cell
phones around so I bought a bunch
of calling cards, I went
into a phone booth right
in front of the KGB building.
And I just -- you can call the
organization, it's an institution
so I called the KGB and I
spoke partly in English,
partly in Russian, depending
who I was talking to.
And I was telling them, look
I need to talk to the director
and they said what
do you want from him.
I said well it's none of your
business if I wanted to talk
to you I would talk to you
but I want to talk to him.
So, and because it's an
hierarchical organization
and they're not really sure
that I'm a kid in front
of the building or it's CIA calling.
So, they always pass
you on to a superior.
And eventually I got all the way
up to the secretary of the director
and she said what do you want and I
said I want to talk to the director
and what do you want from
him and I said I'm not going
to tell you but I'll tell him.
So, she said wait a moment, he
picked up the phone and he said
so how did you get my number?
So I told him and he
started laughing
and he said you know what I'll give
my number now and when you come
to Belarus you can call me and
I'll let you in the archives.
And I said no need I'm in -- if
you look out of the window I'm
in that phone booth
so I'll be right over.
So, he really, he had a
lot of really funny stories
about you know KGB
kind of imaginative,
this invincible organization
and they're actually
not very professional.
I asked him about it
because I was followed,
anyone with a camera is followed
in Belarus and I had some tricks
and I knew they went
through my stuff.
And I said look are they so
professional that they want me
to know that I'm being followed.
Or so unprofessional
that they don't realize
that I know that I'm being followed?
And he looked at me and said,
you know that I don't know.
But anyway he had a
lot of stories but --
so, he actually allowed
me to go into the archives
and I got some kind of a minder
and we went, they opened.
There were these boxes and
boxes, they took out a few
and there were lots of
other interesting boxes.
Which they did not take out
and there was this little room,
it's a building, it looks scary,
it was built by German POWs
in Stalinist style in the 50's.
And very high ceilings
and very narrow corridors.
I was looking through the
material and there was the guy
who was supposed to keep an eye on
me, he was getting bored obviously
and he said do you mind
if I go for a cigarette.
I'm like smoke a whole pack, any --
so he went out, smoked a cigarette
and he said can I go for
lunch, I'm really hungry.
I said look I have so much
material here, of course go.
So, he left and the moment
he left I started running
around the building kind of a
little afraid I'm going to get lost.
And who has keys for
everything, janitors,
exactly so I found a cleaning lady
and it cost me a couple of dollars
but I did manage to get the keys.
Because even in the super-secret
archive you have to clean the floor.
So, I went actually, I
needed to confirm some things
that Czech partisans told me
and German partisans told me.
So I found the boxes,
I was a little sweaty
because if they caught me I probably
would have spent a little more time
in Belarus than I would have liked.
But sometimes you have to get
material in this way as well.
And actually on the other -- I'll
play another, this is from a film
that we are not screening,
here, if you are interested
in actually seeing the films, two
of them are screening tomorrow.
This is from the first
film about Latvia.
>> It was indescribable, You
didn't save anything for later
and you ate it because you
didn't know what happened to you,
somebody might steal it out of
your pocket, which also happened.
[Foreign language]
If you live under cruel
circumstances,
you become cruel yourself
[foreign language].
>> Lukas Pribyl: Yeah, for example
these are stories that you have
to really establish a
relationship with this person
because sometimes they admitted
to killing people and so on,
no one tells you that after
talking to you for 20 minutes.
So, even I -- sometimes after
I interview these people,
then once it's like a
well, once you dig the well
and you connect the --
people start talking.
So, I've seen a lot of interviews of
the same people, I was the first one
to talk to them, they are very
different in the interviews with me
because even then they left out the
things of this nature for example.
I just a week ago talked to
the daughter of one of the men
who was actually a
doctor in the camp.
And they liquidated
some of the bad CAPOs
because whenever they were sick
he was giving them injections not
to help them but to get rid of them.
So these were some of the examples,
I'll take some questions
now I guess.
>> Gail Shirazi: We have
time for a few questions
and then later informally
we can maybe [inaudible].
>> There's a showing
tomorrow [inaudible].
>> Lukas Pribyl: The question was
about the screenings tomorrow,
there are two screenings,
one is at 2:00
at the United States Holocaust
Museum and the other one is
at Congregation Beth
El in the evening.
If you take a leaflet there and
go to our web page the exact time
and place is on the
front in the news,
so just go to forgottentransport.com
and you can find the
information about the screenings.
[inaudible]
>> And I'm wondering do you
have footage in your film
about Poland, do you
have [inaudible].
>> Lukas Pribyl: Did you all hear
the question or should I repeat it?
Yeah, the lady's parents
were from Czech
and she's asking whether I
have some footage from Lodz.
Actually I did not, there was
several deportation schemes really
and deportation directions and I
decided to not to talk about Lodz
because Lodz was less known
than Auschwitz but more known
than all these places
that I was interested in.
But I can tell you there are films
by Pawel Stengel, a film maker
and he used some footage, or all
the footage that's known from Lodz
and he also interviewed
quite a few people
that were deported
to the Lodz Ghetto.
That why I decided not
to do it because I felt
that this area has been
covered more than others.
>> Gail Shirazi: We have time
for one more question, yes.
>> I just want to [inaudible].
>> Lukas Pribyl: Oh,
thank you very much.
[inaudible]
Oh, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Part of it is actually now
I consider myself lucky
that I wasn't a film maker
when I started doing this
because I couldn't get the grant
because whenever I told anyone look,
I want to make four feature length
documentaries about the Holocaust,
I want to do it in a
little different way.
And they asked me so what
film school did you go
to and I said none.
And you know have you ever
held a camera and I said no.
So, they showed me the door very
quickly, so I had lots of time
because I did not have deadlines.
So the films actually took ten years
to make and as I said they took me
to five continents and 20 countries.
And we got stuff from Nazi
families in Argentina and Egypt
and we've been to Eastern Europe,
Australia, everywhere with it.
But I could afford to wait
and that's very important
if you're doing this because for
example sometimes you even got a
response two years later.
When I was looking for --
I would never use a story unless
I could document it with a time
and place precise picture
or footage.
So I have one story that's really
incredible but maybe I would save it
for -- because it relates to Estonia
and you need to see the film.
It's a Romeo and Juliet story
in the film, it's incredible,
I was looking for the one picture
of the girl for four years.
I talked to several hundred
people in the process.
But you're looking for a picture
of a particular Nazi for example
and you only know the name so
I write to everyone in Germany
of that name and then I wait.
And two years later you get
the picture in an envelope,
no return address, but in the
meantime I found the picture
of the Nazi so I can
compare it, because also even
if it get the picture
I wouldn't use it
without actually making sure
that this is the person.
Now things are so much easier,
I was at the very beginning I
befriended people in the police
to help me with facial
recognition software now.
You can see this and
it's so easy now.
But what you cannot do now
is you can identify people,
you can identify pictures
if you know
but you cannot connect
them to stories.
I was very, very lucky that
I could find this material
and still match it with the words.
Now when you have material you
have the words, can connect it.
But yeah, so I had the
advantage of time and patience
because that was the
only way to do it.
And I knew that there
must be a picture,
you just had to wait for it.
And if you have a deadline
from TV that's sponsoring the
film then you can't do it.
So I always try to turn
disadvantages into advantages.
Thank you
[ Applause ]
>> Gail Shirazi: I
want to thank Lukas
for his very interesting devotion
and work and thank you for coming
to LC, thank you and
thank you all for coming.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of congress, visit us at LOC.gov.